[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à bas les voleurs à balai volant
combien sont ils à la nuit tombée sur la
place de la concorde le 6 février 1934 à
pousser ce cri
à bas les voleurs
divoux
20 minutes trente mille on ne sait pas
en tout cas une foule immense et qui
répète à main les voleurs à balai volant
mais qui sont ces voleurs
et bien justement s'ils sont la place de
la concorde
dans ce froid de la fin d'une journée
humide
c'est parce qu'ils veulent prendre le
palais bourbon qui est là-bas au delà du
pont gardé par la force publique prendre
le palais bourbon où se trouvent les
voleurs ou tout au moins les complices
des voleurs les députés qu'il devine
tapis là bas dans leur hémicycle à bas
les voleurs à bas les voleurs
19h29
exactement
un coup de feu
il vient d'on ne sait d'où un coup de
feu le premier coup de feu et la
tragédie comment
alors le 6 février 1934 qu'est ce que
c'est pourquoi y at il eu le 6 février
est ce l'effet d'un complot on l'a
beaucoup on l'a beaucoup écrit
et pourtant un observateur lucide alfred
fabre luce
dira
qu'il s'agit d'une fête sanglante de
l'incohérence française complot
incohérences voilà une antinomie absolue
alors nous allons chercher justement
s'il s'agit ou non d'un complot
il ya quinze ans que la france gagne la
guerre le 11 novembre précédent on a
fêté avec enthousiasme
le 15e anniversaire du 11 novembre
et ces gens qui étaient rentrés de la
guerre les survivants ceux là se sont
souvenus
il était rentré certain que l'on
retrouverait la france plus grande plus
fière que jamais
et aussi
cette sécurité de vie cette stabilité ce
francs or
cette france banquière de l'univers dont
il avait gardé le souvenir et qui était
la réalité d'avant 1914 quelle
désillusion
ce qu'ils ont découvert
c'est l'inflation il ne connaissait même
pas le sens du mot inflation
elles ont vu un franc qui perdait de
mois en mois d'année en année de sa
valeur
et puis un jour
wall street jeudi noir
ça avait été la crise qui un an plus
tard avait gagné l'europe et deux ans
plus tard la france
[Musique]
on y était en plein au début de 1934
dans la crise tout le monde en souffre
et les paysans l'industrie le commerce
les salariés eux-mêmes baisse absolue du
pouvoir d'achat les rentiers ne vivent
presque plus la jeunesse sans espoir
l'horizon bouché
la certitude que l'on avait perdu la
victoire
et c'est de cela que les anciens
combattants 7 millions d'anciens
combattants en charge il y attendent
leurs camarades qui sont restés là bas à
verdun wire eux sont rentrés ils ont
versé leur sang mais pourquoi pour cela
pour cet échec pour cette amertume pour
ce matin
[Musique]
alors ils ne savent pas encore les
français que c'est fini le temps où un
pays n'existait que par lui-même
maintenant c'est fait la france dépend
de l'économie mondiale déjà
mais ils accusent eux le système
et c'est vrai que le système politique
paraît grippe et voilà que le moteur ne
fonctionne plus qu'avec des soubresauts
capricieux on a l'impression que là bas
au parlement ces députés que l'on l'a
envoyé ne pense qu'à jouer un jeu entre
un jeu de massacre puis au pouvoir il
faut que tu partes je prenne sa place et
puis un autre encore 30 gouvernements de
1920 à 1934
[Musique]
là
et la colère qui monte et puis les
scandales et porte le nom leurs
promoteurs ou steak malaman au
nôtre
des milliers de petits épargnants
ruinés et les pouvoirs qu'il espère on
le pense on le dit on le crie alors
c'est une nausée qui est monté un mépris
pour ce personnel politique vous savez
il y a toujours eu en france un vieil
antiparlementarisme larvée si ça va bien
à condition qu'il y ait des époques où
les choses ont été bien ça n'est pas
trouvée si ça va bien ben on laisse un
peu les parlementaires jouer leur jeu si
ça va mal on les désigne alors prendre
et c'est le cas ça va très mal
alors il y a des gens qui maintenant
délibérément en france veulent que ça
change et d'abord
des ligues c'est leur nom des ligues
politiques qui jouent ou contre la
démocratie parlementaire ou contre tout
simplement la république ceux qui jouent
entre la république s'est par exemple
action français l'action française
mouvement royaliste dont le promoteur
dont le chef est le vieil obstiné
charles maurras sourds rageur éclatant
de talent c'est un grand écrivain
mais justement cette immense talent il
le met au service de la polémique du
pamphlet dans les colonnes de son
journal l'action français il étale en
première page et ailleurs plusieurs
colonnes chaque matin de théorie
politique mais les tranches de la faire
c'est que ce vieil humaniste familier de
l'antiquité grecque de l'antiquité
latine cet homme qui pense au célibat de
la provence la mine mistral peut se
révéler un homme qui incitent à la
guerre civile il écrit on les lit noir
sur blanc et bien l'instant est venu
déguisé les poignards ça n'est pas une
formule il écrira et bien maintenant la
solution c'est de tirer de tirer à vue
et moi charles morin qui est 67 ans je
prends des sorties
[Musique]
toujours plus tôt au printemps en d2
chantant les juifs et de l'argent
et puis là près de lui un autre homme de
talent qui s'appelle léon daudet le fils
d'alphonse d'alphonse daudet le petit
chose
léon lui avec un humour aux normes une
allégresse gargantua et bien il écrase
ses adversaires politiques de ces
découvertes de style et dénonce les
désignent à la vad et qu'il trouve des
mots très drôle d'ailleurs albert
sarraut devient albert salon herriot
c'est l'imposteur chaleureux
paul raynaud c'est le petit putois
mirobolants et quant à camille chautemps
celui qui est au pouvoir l'anc on
commence l'année 1934 il est président
du conseil est bien camille chautemps il
va l'appeler lust avis que pour des
raisons que nous allons comprendre
immédiatement se trouve alors on lit
l'action française et on écoute et à
côté du journal il ya un parti il y à
une ligue et elle est importante
elle regroupe soixante mille adhérents
en france dont 8300 sur paris et surtout
parmi les huit mille trois cents on
dispose de 2000 camelots du roi ce sont
des jeunes gens
organisés et qu'ils peuvent sous la
conduite de leur chef maurice pujo se
plonger quand on voudra dans des actions
de rue et ils ne s'en privent pas
[Musique]
alors voilà ça c'est l'action française
elle a un but jeter la république par la
fenêtre écraser cette démocratie et
mettre le roi aux pauvres le roi c'est
le concret qui est venu couronner
l'abstraction de mars alors on crie vive
le roi remet ce qu'écrivent les vive le
roi à l'action française sont surtout
ceux qui détestent qui haïssent la
république autres ligues les jeunesses
patriotes c'est un député de paris un
conseiller municipal de paris pierre
taittinger qui les a réunis c'est un
homme qui dispose d'une vaste fortune
qu'il a mises à la disposition de ce
mouvement et les jeunesses patriotes
réunissent trois cent mille adhérents en
france dont 35 milles dans la seine et
ils ont également 15 cents membres des
groupes mobiles l'équivalent des
camelots du roi voilà encore 15 100
garçons bien organisé bien entraînés à
pouvoir éventuellement lancer dans la
rue ils défilent avec des chemises
bleues avec un béret basque on voit très
bien où ça peut aller alors à côté ça il
ya des plus petits par exemple la
solidarité française dix mille adhérents
qui se calque tout simplement sur le
faste
[Musique]
une autre ligne le franquisme dirigé par
un certain marcel bucard qui également
rêve d'être mussolini français parce que
c'est ça le rêve de certains
développements pas de tous mais de
certains oui solide on regarde du côté
de rome on regarde du côté des super
pouvoirs c'est vrai que le don de chats
remis de l'ordre en italie et on pense
qu'il faut remettre de l'ordre enfants
alors évidemment les manques de la
solidarité française comme les pacistes
ont des uniformes qui s'apparente
beaucoup à ceux des fassis une solide
[Musique]
il jouit généralement
pour rivaux
la finale dames au l'aromathérapie
[Musique]
mais il existe un autre rassemblement
qui pèse beaucoup plus lourd encore
ce sont les anciens combattants ils sont
regroupés principalement dans l'union
nationale des combattants ufc
qui regroupe 900 mhz il adhère
900 mille adhérents dont 72 milles dans
la seine
bien sûr ces combattants ne font pas de
politique que dans leur statut il leur
est interdit de faire de la politique
mais voilà il ya la crise mais voilà il
y là lily a le massacre de la victoire
mais voilà il y a les illusions perdues
il y a les scandales il y à cette
cascade de ministères qui écoeure
cette impression que l'on court vers le
gouffre parce qu'on n'est pas gouvernée
et depuis quelques temps les anciens
combattants proteste aussi ils tiennent
des réunions où l'on condamne l'action
du gouvernement il ya encore les croix
de feu du colonel de la rampe à
l'origine ce n'était que des anciens
combattants
décoré au front pendant la guerre nous
le terme de croix de feu et puis on a
élargi on a accepté des fils et filles
de croix de feu et puis on a exalté le
rassemblement national et puis on la
crée des volontaires nationaux et tout
cela fait des troupes considérable
215000 croix de feu en france dont 100
milles dans la seine songé cent mille
naît ce qu'on peut les jeter dans un
combat de rue
m
[Musique]
aulas
robe en
de l'autre côté c'est vrai il y à des
rassemblements
[Musique]
il ya des jeunesses socialistes
il y a des jeunesses l'oeil qui lie à la
jeune république il y à là jeunesse
communiste mais disons le franchement
ce sont surtout les jeunesses
communistes qui font parler d'elles
elles sont agi sans elle les autres les
autres pour n'en parle pas beaucoup tant
il est vrai qu'en 1934 la jeunesse
intellectuelle par exemple elle est
beaucoup plus à droite qu'à gauche
en tout cas oui en tout cas
le rideau va pouvoir se lever puisque le
décor est planté les figurants ils sont
encore dans la coulisse ils attendent
les ordres du ou des metteurs en scène
le rideau va pouvoir se lever sur le
premier acte de la tragédie cet acte un
titre qui est un nom staviski
c'est le 24 décembre 1933 qu'à bayonne
la police a arrêté un certain tissier
directeur du crédit municipal c'est à
dire du mont-de-piété
on l'a découvert que ce tissier avait
mis en circulation pour 200 millions de
l'époque sommes énormes
de faux bond caisses du crédit municipal
escroquerie sans exemple alors tissier
interrogé va dire ce que j'ai fait je ne
les fais que parce que monsieur garat
mela ordonnait il m'a dit que c'était
une opération honnête qui égare assez le
député maire de bayonne député-maire
radical
radical et j'insiste parce que nous
sommes dans une france radical le
président du conseil qui est au pouvoir
s'appelle camille chautemps il est
radical
et la troisième république depuis
longtemps est une république radical
et on va arrêter garin car c'est vrai
qui la protégeait tissier et c'est vrai
qu'il a couverts l'escroquerie et voilà
ce député radical en prison inculpés de
faux usage de faux escroquerie
et voilà de la boue qui couvre le
radicalisme le gouvernement à la chambre
d'autant plus qu'on apprend qu'un
ministre de show temps d'aligner
adressé une circulaire aux compagnies
d'assurance et le radis acheter des bons
de bayonne je vous le recommande
comment l'escroquerie soutenu par un
député
radical par un ministre radical
et l'on apprend que les conseillers
de celui qui est dans l'ombre sont aussi
des radicaux mais qui est dans l'ombre
et bien c'est un certain monsieur alex
ans qui depuis des années brasse des
normes a fait qui depuis des années est
une vedette parisienne que l'on voit
partout dans les répétitions générales
dans les banques et dans les salons qui
achetait un théâtre l' empire qui a deux
journaux une femme très belle qui gagne
les concours d'élégance elle s'appelle
arlette
il a un immeuble entier pour ses bureaux
place saint georges il a pignon sur rue
dans ces conseils d'administration dans
les conseils de ces sociétés il y à des
personnages éminents il est un général
de division
il est un ambassadeur grand officier de
la légion d'honneur il y à un ex préfet
de police mais oui monsieur alexandre le
respecte on le salue c'est lui qui a des
journaux
seul ex entre n'existe pas c'est un
prénom alexandre c'est celui de stavisky
fils d'un dentiste petits larcins 18 ans
petites escroqueries pile ambitions
libyen est tout à coup une vaste
escroquerie 14 millions dérobés grâce un
chèque falsifié
c'est trop gros ou même alors on le
recherche sur le rejoint on l'arrête 17
mois de prison alors ils payent des
médecins ils payent des avocats les
médecins déclarent que il est très
malade qu'il va mourir en prison
libération médical
et dès lors ses avocats ses protecteurs
pour faire en sorte qu'il ne retourne
jamais en prison bien qu'il n'ait pas
été jugée
et il devient monsieur alexandre
métamorphose complète adieu le petit
escroc salue monsieur alexandre et ses
affaires ses sociétés
or tout cela est du vent
les fonds à l'origine les fonds de ces
sociétés viennent du crédit municipal
d'orléans
on n'y a à placer deux fosses émeraude
et sur ces fausses d'émeraude on
attirait des bons de caisse
un jour on la fait découvrir la faire il
a remboursé monsieur alexandre il avait
l'argent il s'est rabattu sur bayonne on
a recommencé l'opération à bayonne
et oui ces conseils juridiques s'appelle
bonnaure
député radical
renoue
sénateur radical
alors
alors la colère se lève il faut lire dès
que le pot-aux-roses se découvre les
titres de la presse la presse de droite
d'extrême droite bien sûr mais aussi la
presse modéré mais aussi la presse de
gauche on n'en peut plus on ne peut plus
supporter une chose pareille on pense
que toute la france parlementaire est
pourri c'est faux ils le sont que une
vingtaine le reste et intègre honnête
mais on ne voit que cela le scandale
éclabousse tout le reste alors pendant
tout le mois de janvier à l'appel des
journaux tels que l'action française qui
mène le branle disons le et bien sans
arrêt on se bat dans la rue
[Musique]
on
inga tous les deux ou trois jours des
émeutes qui tourne à l'insurrection se
bat pendant des heures notamment sur le
faubourg saint-germain et la nuit à
minuit quand ça se termine gars des
kiosques incendié des arbres arrachés
des pouilles hobby mais tendue sur le
piquet
[Applaudissements]
comme manifeste partout même à la
comédie française parce que monsieur
émile fabre l'administrateur général a
eu l'idée singulière de monter juste à
ce moment là coriolan une pièce de
shakespeare qu'on connaît mal qui
raconte l'histoire d'un général qui
autrefois dans l'antiquité a voulu s'en
prendre sénat corrompue alors il ya des
répliques il faut venir à bout de ces
parlementaires corrompus alors vous
imaginez les cris dans la salle c'est
plus un théâtre c'est un meeting tous
les soirs
on apprend que logiquement stavisky
aurait dû comparaître devant un tribunal
depuis qu'il est sorti de sa prison et
en effet il était convoqué dix-neuf fois
devant les tribunaux
et il y a eu 19 remise
et ce parc est tout de même averti par
des rapports de police qu est ce qu il
faisait rien du tout rien
et qui dirige le parquet le procureur
presse à écuyer le procureur prayssas le
bon frère de camille chautemps le
président du conseil alors imaginez que
vous soyez là en train de vivre votre
vie en 1934 et parmi ceux qui m'écoutent
qu'il y en a qui ont vécu cela
les corman le mépris
et la colère et on peut comprendre une
chose pareille un sentiment paraît même
s'il n'est pas vraiment justifié
alors on manifeste et le 27 janvier
camille chautemps baisse les bras il
démissionne voilà le président de la
république albert lebrun
bien embarrassé qui va-t-il désigné
comme président du conseil il faut un
homme indiscutable un homme qui fasse
l'union des partis et il pense à
l'ancien président de la république
doumergue gaston pour la peine gastoon
est parce qu on aime bien
alors il a pris sa retraite il a 70 ans
il est à tournefeuille dans sa résidence
méridionale et au téléphone dit non à
l'oeuvre
et le brun va se tourner vers edouard
daladier pourquoi edouard daladier parce
que c'est l'heure fort du parti radical
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui a déboulonné
edouard herriot il suffit de le voir il
a l'air d'un homme avec ce front c'est
par quatre sur six est regard il respire
l'énergie comme il est député du
vaucluse on l'appelle d'ailleurs le
taureau du vaucluse alors il faut un
taureau espère comme ça il désigne
edouard daladier en se disant il sera
faire régner l'ordre de nouveau
et c'est le temps où justement l'union
nationale des combattants veut
manifester l'ufc déclare qu'elle va
organiser une immense manifestation est
de la ville il vient d'arriver au
pouvoir va demander au préfet de police
cap de négocier avec le président de
l'ufc monsieur le mec
jean kape le préfet de police va voir le
président des combattants et arrivent à
un accord monsieur le bec dis bien pour
le moment nous n'allons pas manifester
qui happe et fiers et heureux de cette
réussite
et de là ils veulent félicité huo tous
genres tiab quatre
soirs là
fatigués mais la peine de lire les
événements de la journée il est très
émue de l'attitude des anciens
combattants il a été profondément touché
et termine sa conversation va dix ans
enfin cette nuit je vais pouvoir dormir
qu'il n'y a pas de manifestation demain
et pourtant c'est de ce même cap
que va découler tout le drame qui va sur
jean piat inutile de dire qu'il est
corse
il a suivi une carrière administrative
logique et il est arrivé à la préfecture
de police il y à cette entente illicite
roues
et qu'il est populaire sa silhouette est
connu de tous à paris ne pas quand des
tout petits mais bien de cambrai dans
cette pratique talent il a un masque que
ses amis disent volontiers impérial ils
étaient les grands
et on le voit partout
et puis les populaires aussi auprès de
ces policiers on aime bien le patron et
d'ailleurs madame gens qui happe a de
ses propres deniers créé la maison de
santé des gardiens de la paix qui a
coûté très cher où on accueille les
policiers malades ou blessés et cela
ajouter encore à la popularité de kia
toujours vous vous êtes prêts en chine
sur ceux qui soufflent toujours nous
avait apporté le réconfort moral
nécessaire pour aider au rétablissement
physique de mes camarades de ces ratés
par leurs blessures de guerre de tout
cela bram nous vous en remercions
profondément et vous et nous en sommes
profondément reconnaissants le conseil
d'administration a décidé de vous
décerner la médaille d'or de notre
société
je serai aux yeux de certains l'or n'a
plus aucune valeur possède d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils ne l'ont plus dans les
caisses natation donc pas d'importance à
cette raquette mais néanmoins accepté là
comme vous êtes vous est offert avec
lotto restait leur amitié et tout le
côté
oui mais voilà il ya eu la first à
risque or qui a pas une formule j'aime
mieux prévenir que sévir c'est
probablement vrai mais depuis qu'il est
là pendant sept ans il y avait beaucoup
de manifestations dans les rues de paris
disons qu'en démocratie on manifeste
beaucoup je pense qu'on la raison c'est
le propre de la démocratie de dire quand
il le faut ce qu'on a dit alors le
propre des policiers céder également
d'être dans la rue pour éviter que ça
tourne mal et les policiers de cap sont
dans la rue chaque fois qu'on manifeste
et j'ai pas s'il prévient mais quand
même il sévit
[Musique]
où
vis-à-vis des manifestants la droite
ont sévi mais pas trop méchamment c'est
pas le cas des manifestants de gauche là
les policiers frappent du il ya deux
différences de traitement qui n'ont
naturellement pas échappé
à la droite ni à la gauche ce qui fait
que qui happe et populaire à droite et
qu'il ne l'est pas du tout ago
et quand la sphère ce thalys qui
éclatent les journaux de gauche disent
mais enfin ce monsieur qui happe qui est
depuis sept ans à la préfecture de
police
et n'a rien vu rien connu rien entendu
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire nous
avons vu qu'il ya des ministres complice
de stavisky des députés complice de cet
avis qu'est ce que monsieur cap préfet
de police n'est pas un des complices de
stavisky et l'accusation grave et on
précise on dit par exemple qu'il a
rencontré stavisky dans son bureau qu'il
a assisté à une représentation de la
pièce katinka dans la loge de stavisky
on voit même un caricaturiste montrant
dans cette loge qui happe passant
affectueusement la main sur l'épaule de
stavisky et la légende est la suivante
monsieur kg hap met la main au collet de
stavisky c'est pas très aimable tout ça
ça fait sourire mais également
voilà la réputation de cap compromise
car ce point qu'on va désigner à
l'enquêteur vous savez que quand un
policier mis en cause il y à
l'inspection générale
c'est-à-dire la police des polices et
c'est monsieur mossé qui est désigné qui
va faire une enquête et déposé un
rapport qui est un modèle du genre où
tout est épluché ce qui s'est passé à la
préfecture de police et que conclut
mossé et bien il dit que les hommes de
la préfecture de police ont bien su ce
que faisait cet avis qui notamment il ya
des rapports du commissaire pas chaude
et rapport de l'inspecteur cous ces
rapports ont été acheminés au parquet le
parquet de prayssas qu'il a rien fait
mais il ya notamment un rapport celui de
couze un qui est resté dans le tiroir du
chef de cabinet de monsieur cap qui
s'appelle monsieur zimmer le chef de
cabinet pendant des mois
et ça c'est au moins de la négligence
quant à cap
monsieur mot s'est dit que
rien ne vient porter atteinte à son
honorabilité
les entrevues dont on a parlé sont fous
il n'a jamais eu elle commence à l'oeuf
stavisky il a vu une fois dans son
bureau mais s'est amenée par du baril un
homme politique un directeur de journal
et l'a reçue debout pendant 3 minutes et
stavisky était venu avec un culot
immense eux pleurent de la surveillance
de police dont il était victime
alors on en est là
pourtant le 1er février daladier vient
d'arriver aux pauvres
la pression est très forte sur le
gouvernement pour eux qu'on renvoie qui
à corps on voit également tôt mais le
directeur de la sûreté
et le nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
du gouvernement il s'appelle eugène
front c'est à l'ancien socialiste dit
sinon il est maintenant mené au social
réclame la tête de pia
également la sûreté réclame la tête de
pia
daladier ne se prononcent pas il attend
pour se prononcer le 3 février
parce que là il a maintenant le rapport
mossé entre l'aiment
et un jeune historien serge bernstein
a pu publier il y à peu des extraits du
journal intime inédit de daleh et il dit
explicitement dans ce journal
qu'il approuve les conclusions rien ne
vient porter atteinte à l'honorabilité
de cap en revanche les graves
négligences
doivent être sanctionnés
révocation de cap non ce serait trop
alors vous savez nous sommes sous la
troisième république on trouve toujours
des moyens de sa aurait on va procéder à
un vaste mouvement
on va nommer un nouveau procès de police
et on va proposer un cap la résidence
général du maroc à rabat c'est un
avancement foudroyant est un poste
mirifiques quand atom et le directeur de
la sûreté on va l'envoyer à la comédie
française parce qu'on va demander la
démission de monsieur fabre qui a monté
coriolan on trouve que tomer sera très
bien la comédie française q ce qui est
vraiment quand on y pense hallucinant
cette idée là et on pense que
quelquefois nos gouvernants sont bien
étranger au monde de la culture et
prennent des décisions
invraisemblable alors le 3 février
daladier veut annoncer lui même la
nouvelle acquis ap il l'appelle au
téléphone qui a fait coucher avec une
sciatique qui lui faut longtemps pour
venir au téléphone et un dialogue
s'engage dans du possédant deux versions
bien sûr la version kia mais aussi la
version daladier et les versions se
recoupent pour les débuts de la
conversation mon char cap bonne nouvelle
vous êtes nommé résident général à rabat
vous succédez à lyautey monsieur le
président du conseil je serai très fier
de succéder à lyautey mais je refuse
mais pourquoi refusez-vous et bien parce
que mon honneur est en cause on
m'attaque comporte contre moi de graves
accusations je dois rester à paris pour
défendre mon honneur et daladier qui
insistent et cap qui refuse et
finalement le ton devient plus dur qui a
page ou deux je sais très bien ce qui
m'attend mais c'est le président du
conseil
si je refuse vous allez me révoquer et
bien tant pis
je suis entré il ya sept ans à la
préfecture de police avec ma femme qui
suis entré riches
j'en sors pauvres mais honnête je serai
ce soir à la rue
voilà ce que aditya
mais voilà daladier n'a pas tout à fait
entendu la même chose
il a entendu à la fin eh bien puisque
c'est comme ça je serai ce soir dans la
rue à dans la rue et manifestent tous
les soirs alors ça veut dire qu'il va
prendre sa place à côté des manifestants
comment savoir qui a raison
il ya quelqu'un dans la chambre le cap
c'est son chef de cabinet du maire il a
noté la conversation et dans ces notes
il y à bien je serai ce soir à la rue
alors c'est cap qui a raison attention
daladier a pris la précaution de tendre
l'écouteur à monsieur clavier son chef
de cabinet monsieur klein à noter je
serai ce soir dans la rue alors de
contretemps qui peut ça
en tout cas c'est la version de daladier
qui va être soumise au conseil des
ministres et là monsieur albert lebrun
le président de la république qui en
général pleure en toute occasion est
bien là il est très fâché monsieur
lebrun et il est tellement fait ce qu'il
dit n'est plus question du maroc et on
est et on va révoqué tient le 5 jean et
mamans viennent habiter quitte la
préfecture de police hall une foule
anxieuse à temps aux portes les gens
applaudissent des agents de vieux sage
ampleur et il arrive chez moi 13 jan
peut-être bon pour en vouloir à
quiconque il était déçu et un peu
écoeuré la latitude certains politiciens
ma mère était très fatigué est prévu
cette maison où vous êtes ce salon n'est
disparaissait sous les fleurs envoyées
on ne pouvait plus les montées en avait
dans l'escalier y en avait partout des
gens inconnus des petits bouquets
touchant une manifestation est les
sympathies
bouleversante alors il faut lire les
journaux
selon nous c'est une explosion de colère
à droite de joie
et déjà
on prévoit qu on va manifester contre le
renvoi de kia l'union nationale des
combattants déclare qu'elle reprend sa
parole puisque cette parole avait été
donnée un cap et qu'on va manifester le
6 février
et les ligues
distribuer dans les rues des tracts que
monsieur marcel leclerc dans son livre
sur le 6 février a pu retrouver publiées
et tous convoque curieusement à la même
heure leurs adhérents il n'y a que les
lieux qui changent l'action française
s'est directement place de la concorde
les jeunesses patriotes à l'hôtel de
ville la solidarité française à
richelieu-drouot mais toujours en fin
d'après midi après la fermeture des
bureaux et des ateliers le 6 février
alors ça va chauffer on en est sûr
et
ces groupes qui se prépareront un but
faire voler en éclats tous les édifices
parlementaires peut-être tout l'édifice
démocratique et en ce qui concerne
l'action française tout la république et
le jour du 6 février l'aube du 6 février
se lève
un vent frais à chasser pendant la nuit
labrie ne fait pas très chaud mais pas
très froid
et pendant la matinée les
elling
fourbissent leurs armes on se prépare
par exemple on installe des lames de
rasoir au bout de bâtons parce qu'on
sait qu'il y aura des chevaux dans le
service d'ordre et c'est très bien de
pouvoir couper les jarrets des chevaux
justement avec ses lames de rasoir
[Musique]
quant à la police à toutes les polices
elle se prépare que ce soit les gars qui
amenèrent pena gardes mobiles le garde
républicaine
on a rempli les réservoirs des camions
dans l'île de la cité et les chevaux
reçu leur pression d'un voile
[Musique]
alors le fait que tous ces gens se
soient donnés le mot
j'étais en complot ça paraît cette fois
évident
pas tellement ces gens là ne sont pas
des gens qui s'associent pour un coup
d'état
un coup d'état ça voudrait dire quoi
s'emparer du poids alors on ne
marcherait pas seulement sur le palais
bourbon alors on aurait un plan se
saisir et des ministères on se saisirait
de la préfecture de police on se saisir
et des gares du réseau téléphonique du
réseau télégraphique du réseau
radiophonique
rien n'est prévu de pareilles simplement
marchera sur le palais bonbons et là des
protagonistes du moulin de labarthe est
interrogé répondra nous n'avions qu'un
but rentrer dans le palais bourbon et là
vous livrer à la punition des députés
coupables aux hommes ils voulaient
fessée les députés c'est presque ça me
voyez vous ce genre d'opération on sait
quand ça commence on ne sait pas
comment ça finit est ce que les gens qui
voulaient prendre la bastille le 14
juillet 1789 savais qu'au bout de la
route qui lui aurait la république la
terreur robespierre la patrie en danger
on ne peut jamais savoir où alors on est
prêt des deux côtés à midi monsieur
daladier des jeunes chez un sénateur rue
copernic 25 ouvert cinq maîtres d'hôtel
homard thermidor poularde truffé 20
somptueux et l'on remarque monsieur
daladier bois sec à 14h30 sa voiture
bien le prendre le conduit au palais
bourbon qui est déjà
formidablement garde
il doit lire sa déclaration
ministérielle
à 15 heures ils mentent à la tribu c'est
chambre des grands jours pas un député
qui ne soit son banc les tribunes sont
bondés
et il est la plus obstinée le taureau du
vaucluse plus tant au niveau plus que
jamais
et il tient ses papiers
dans une main qui tremble un peu elle
commence à parler et déjà des
interjections qui fusent à droite et à
gauche on la taxe des deux côtés
et on crie si fort on l'a jury si fort
qu'il ne peut pas se faire entendre il
n'y a pas de micro en ce temps là la
chambre alors il s'adosse
à la tribune et il attend
et ça va durer des heures
cette clameur immense qui monte vers la
verrière
de l'hémicycle clameur
peut-être sans exemple tous se croisent
les mots les injures les invectives les
accusations nées vérité les calomnies
cet affreux médor
et bien deux orgues lentement la nuit
tombe et sur la place de la concorde
c'est la même planète mais démultiplier
décuplée déjà à 16 heures il y avait
trois ou quatre cents jeunes gens qui
étaient là qui allaient qui est venu et
c'est seulement à 16h45 et oui est-ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu y penser avant que
le service d'ordre
bar le pont s'est installée d'abord 7/4
à l'entrée du pont qui regardent la
place de la concorde devant ces sept cas
une file de 25 à vallière et à peu près
devant une file de 70 agents
s'est pas beaucoup
et on peut s'attendre un choc énorme le
nouveau préfet de police est là il
s'appelle bonne foi si vous rirez
remplace cap il arrive je verse like in
connais personne chaque fois qu'il aura
un ordre à donner le vrai bien attention
c'est moi le préfet c'est pas très
pratique ce jour les moeurs monsieur
marchand le directeur adjoint de la
police
le second parce que le directeur
malheureusement vient d'être opéré de
l'appendicite
peu à peu la foule arrive elle arrive de
partout
[Applaudissements]
la nuit 3000 4000
le bruit mode la mode à bas les voleurs
à bas les voleurs y pioche
pour s'inquiéter du serviteur mais ce
que ça finira jamais non affirmé
[Musique]
et bientôt la place et toi de monde avec
cette chose quitte à ne pas croire c'est
que la circulation ne s'arrête pas c'est
qu'au milieu de cette foule inextricable
et bien les voitures tâche de passer
même les autobus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
et même cependant que la tension monte
les manifestants qui sont maintenant des
nouilles et des milliers voit arriver de
la rue royale un autobus ils vont le
pousser à l'obélisque mettre le feu à
cet autobus
et maintenant ils prennent de partout
tout ce qu'ils ont alors forte pour le
jeter sur le service d'ordre on a édifié
une barricade du côté de la place de la
concorde qui regardent le quai des
tuileries en acheter des sièges durs ou
des tuileries et puis aussi des arcs
profondes ce qui servit à limiter les
allées on les a pris et on les garçons
les lances sur les policiers qui vont
d'abord restés pendant plus d'une heure
stoïque immobile recevoir en plein
visage
ces projectiles cette fonte c'est boulot
[Applaudissements]
et puis à partir d'un moment ils vont
les ramasser et les plans c'est sur la
foulée ce sont les premiers blessés de
part et d'autre
j'ai vu arriver au palais bourbon des
gens qui étaient blessés des soldats
beaucoup de soldats et civils pour
cibles et qu'ils étaient surtout blessé
aux jambes
et au visage
et ces gens se dirigeaient vers la cour
d'honneur je suis descendu
avec mon père qui ne voulait pas
d'ailleurs et j'ai eut été frappé par
tous ces blessés qui sont dirigés
portés par leurs camarades vers une
ancienne mairie provisoire
un docteur dr du palais-bourbon qu'était
le docteur de députés
soignait à soigner ses blessés
en quantité et à l'époque aussi il y
avait le questeur qui était pharmacien
épi li a aidé à soigner tous ces blessés
entre autres j'ai vu aussi
un lieutenant
s'il y avait été coupé au visage très
profondément s'est fait recoudre
évidemment je me cachais pour pas qu'on
voit pas ce que cet ange lève on
chassait et finalement ce lieutenant est
sorti je les ai vus se réarmer son
pistolet
fait lire j'y retourne
et c'est surtout ce qui m'a frappé ce
sont les choses dans la cour d'honneur
mon père avait ouvert lé haut et fort
que ces chevaux qui étaient tous qui
étaient blessés puissent boire lanka
niveau est également sur le devant du
pont de la concorde
le long du trottoir l'eau couler non
fera le ou vers le haut pour créer ce
qu'on puisse boire et j'ai même vu au
milieu de la cour d'honneur un cheval
tombé avec tous les arts est coupée
et puis la pression devient
littéralement un sauna cette foule s'est
approché jusqu'à la touche et
sept gardes qui tient bon malgré tout de
temps en temps il ya les charges de
cavalerie pour essayer de disperser la
foule mais les camelots du roi ont jeté
des vies par terre vous savez ces billes
qui viennent des roulements à bille ou
bien tout simplement pour les enfants et
les je vous glisse sur ses billes en a
qui s'abattent les cavaliers sont
désarçonnés ils sont obligés de se
replier blessé encore mais en pente
et un moment donné la pression est si
forte malgré toutes ses attaques ses
chars
on en voit tellement de projectiles sur
le service d'ordre la foule presse avec
une telle vigueur que monsieur marchand
sans que le service d'ordre va être
emporté alors il appelle un claireaux
qui attend le fait sonner pour prévenir
la foule qu'il va faire c'est sommation
il les fait suivant les termes de la loi
de 1832
obéissance à la loi nous allons employer
la fin
mais la clameur est si forte et tous les
témoins disent
que personne dans les sommations que
personne sauf les premiers rangs dont
même le cléo
mais un grand nombre de journalistes qui
étaient là sur la place dont les récits
se recoupent notamment rené brillet ce
qui est là avec un mot flash entend
écoute ceux venant du cours la reine
riez via flash quelle heure est-il et
flash regarde sa montre
19h29 briouze le note au site et il y à
marcel vont aaron un autre journaliste à
l'angle du pont du côté des tuileries
et ils essuient le tir de deux coups de
feu le réverbère qui est au dessus de sa
tête vole en éclats tes morceaux de
glace tombe sur lui alors question
essentielle d'où venaient ces coups de
feu or moi je suis formel change en
effet le témoignage à plusieurs reprises
je suis formel ces coups de feu ne
pouvait venir que
des bosquets du cours la reine car à ce
moment là vous voyez le cours la reine a
fait dénudée mais il y avait à ce moment
là aux coureurs et aux courbes à rennes
des bosses tu es très touffu de
véritables fourrés et il n'est pas
douteux que ça n'était pas les les
agents qui étaient tac à côté de moi ils
se sont mis à tirer sur le bec de g la
trajectoire d'ailleurs était absolument
indiscutable ses premiers coups de feu
venait du cours la reine
alors un gars
s'appelle richard est blessé et il ya
mouvement terim parmi les gens du
service d'ordre éolien motards de le
pratiquer de police qui dit alors ils
tirent sur nous ils nous canarde et il y
a juste à ce moment là profitant de ce
mouvement des jeunes gens qui arrivent à
se glisser sur le pont passe entre le
parapet et les camions on les a laissé
passer et les journalistes ils sont une
vingtaine qui n'ont pas comme montaron
flash mob riez le courage d'être devant
ils sont derrière eux les journalistes
en les voyant arriver s'enfuir à toutes
jambes en criant sauve qui peut ils ont
forcé le barrage est le cri entre m la
force publique et voilà les gardes qui
détale qui décampe et voilà les
cavaliers qui feront faire volte face à
leurs chevaux et qui au galop je dis
bien en galant s'enfonce vers le palais
bourbon
et il faut à ce moment là que un
lieutenant hurle à l'adresse des
cavaliers arrêtez vous arrêter vous le
18e et marchands et bonne foi ciboure
qui dit arrêtez vous arrêter vous est
alors des gardes s'arrête et retourna
font face à la foule et alors les uns
debout les autres âges nous dire sur
cette île non pas nous ce que ton ils
ont tous des rêves
et les coups de feu part on les a
protégés 53 il ya quatre mois elle est
beaucoup de blessés et la foule
épouvanté reflux on a gagné il ne passe
pas mais à quel prix
alors
est un grand moment de silence et
d'accalmies
et c'est à ce moment là que
les hommes de la solidarité française
savez ceux de richelieu moore déboule
sur la place ils n'ont rien vu rien
entendu leur colère est fraîche ils
n'ont pas peur est de nouveau une
bombarde le service d'ordre et ça
recommence est-ce que ça va durer
toujours et c'est à ce moment-là 20h30
que à la chambre on va se séparer
et oui parce que daladier
tout à coup
à 19h30
daladier a vu se lever le député jean
scappini députés de droite à grand-métis
les guerres il est aveugle et pointant
son index dans la direction du président
du conseil il a crié au pire monsieur le
président du conseil est ce vous qui
avez donné l'ordre de tirer dénégation
épouvanté de daladier non non alors où
est il votre gouvernement d'autorité
vous êtes responsable de tout le sang
coule à cause de vous et à gauche les
députés communistes qui scandent les
soviets les soviets les soviets c'est le
refrain leur leitmotiv du moment oui
sont le président suspend la séance et
pendant la suspension tous les députés
pour voir ce qui se passe et ils voient
les blessés dans les couloirs du palais
bourbon
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de la place il y a des
centaines de blessés parmi les
manifestants que l'ont emporté au café
weber ou à l'hôtel crillon et les
députés voit tout cela et il rentre en
séance et il vote la confiance à
daladier oui voilà une former le
gouvernement après quoi il s'en vend par
derrière et même le douarin rioux 120
sans se rendre compte du danger avec ses
arcs enfin qui est un peu plus loin
edouard herriot va être reconnu par des
croix de ce qu'ils se saisissent de lui
du gros herriot la poster chaleureux
comme disait léon daudet et ont créé à
la scène il faut le noyer et on le porte
vers la scène pour le jeter il ya tout
de même un homme qui dit vous savez il
est pas méchant herriot on devrait se
contenter bleus déculottée alors on
l'emmène pour lui enlever sa culotte
juste à ce moment là elle est libérée
par des agents qui arrive pour le
délivrer alors il remet sa culotte il
est tout rouge heidi aux halles on se
prononce le mot historique dit de toute
façon le maire de lyon ne pouvait être
noyé que dans le rhône et justement à
20h30 voilà que des champs elysées
arrive l'immense cortège
des anciens combattants ils s'étaient
regroupés plus haut dans l'avenue et les
mots viennent à l'heure sur cette étude
c'est 20h30 les voilà qui se lance dans
la place de la concorde sortant des
champs-elysées une immense banderole ils
veulent que vive la france et qu'elle
soit propre et sous cette banderole 40
drapeau est derrière une masse énorme
ils sont là avec leurs décorations sur
la poitrine ils sont là les mutilés ils
chantent la marseillaise en pénétrant
sur la place
et chose curieuse à cette marseillaise
voici que ce mail l'international et
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il ya une
autre association d'anciens combattants
elle est d'essence communiste c'est la
raque l'association républicaine des
anciens combattants et elle manifeste
également pas tout à fait pour les mêmes
buts mais elle est là
et elle chante et ces gens qui sentent
la marseillaise et qui chante
l'internationale et bien non pas
tellement l'air de se gêner et alors les
représentants de la force publique voilà
mme marchand qui s'avance et les autres
ont négocié avec le bec avec les chefs
des anciens combattants on arrive à un
arrangement leur dit vous ne pouvez pas
vous mêler à l'émeute ça n'est pas
possible vous avez des infirmes des
mutilés avec vous
vous avez fait votre démonstration
l'essentiel est fait et le bec se laisse
convaincre on ira défiler sur les grands
boulevards à mon common man rue royale
et l'on repart et l'on chante la
marseillaise et l'internationale
bien sûr les gens de l'arac sont bien
moins nombreux
l'immense masse
c'est l'umc
et voilà que dans la rue royale un
service d'ordre qui n'a pas bien compris
ne
voudrait barrer la route et voilà que le
mec ce sens piégée alors furieux il dit
à bientôt 10 à gauche dans la rue du
faubourg saint-honoré on va marcher sur
l'elysée il s'avance et comme il n'y a
pas de barrage ils vont peut-être
prendre l'elysée et non à 50 mètres de
l'elysée on leur interdit de passer
alors ils vont se disperser dans paris
et finalement certains se retrouveront
sur la place de la concorde et tout d'un
coup alors à 22 heures exactement je
vois des bouchers à ma grande surprise
venant de la madeleine une immense
cortège composé essentiellement de
messieurs respectable bien habillés et
chantant à tue-tête braillant même la
marseillaise et tout autour sur les bas
côtés
les accompagnants des militants
communistes qui de toute évidence et les
communistes puis ce qu'il chantait
l'internationale et que les parmi eux
beaucoup de jeunes après on m'a dit ce
cso des militants de l'arac de
l'association des anciens combattants
révolutionnaires mais il y avait
également beaucoup de jeunes et pourquoi
parce que le matin le parti communiste
dans l'humanité avait appelé à
manifester au rond point des champs
elysées donc savait aussi en et pas
seulement des anciens combattants
commune mais des jeunes donc
la soirée continuait il y avait toujours
très peu de monde sur la ba de la
concorde plutôt des badauds plutôt des
cours et curieux qui avaient entendu
parler des bagarres qui avaient éclaté
qui étaient venus voir les dégâts et
tout d'un coup vers 23h30 on voit le
barrage qui barrait le pont de la
concorde s'ouvrir et des policiers se
précipiter comme au pas de charge à
travers le place de la concorde en
direction des choix de marly en même
temps d'ailleurs je les ai pas vues mais
je laisse eu une autre équipe de
policiers d'assaillants policiers
venaient du cours la reine à travers les
bosquets des champs elysées et alors il
ya eu une véritable charge de des
soi-disant manifestants qui en était à
mon avis n'étaient pas des manifestants
étaient plutôt des curieux à travers les
bosquets les champs-elysées et bagarre
dans laquelle de charges laquelle vous y
trouvez prix alors j'ai d'étaler autant
j'ai vite si hautain aussi vite que j'ai
pu avec mon vélo et j'entendais des
crépitements dans les réverbères des
champs à 10,2 des bosquets ce qui semble
indiquer que on tirait etc ont tiré des
balles qui cassaient les huîtres des
réverbères derrière moi j'ai eu un gros
homme qui courait tout d'un coup je dois
s'affaler partir sur le dos je pense
qu'ils avaient été gravement touché je
vois plus jeunes qui sans qui dit sentir
une brûlure à son oreille team à la main
son oreille et grâce à sa main était
pleine de sens elle va se passer des
choses horribles maintenant qu'il y a
moins de manifestants sur la place les
forces de l'ordre les poursuivent
notamment dans les bosquets du cours la
reine et quand on ne ratera pas on le
jette à terre on le piétinons le bass
sauvagement et puis même on en tue et à
l'officier qui dit celui là je le veux
on le lui laisse il tire
mais quand vers 23h30 la place ravie on
comptera les morts
15h14 du côté des manifestants
et des centaines de blessés un mort du
côté du service d'ordre et 1060 l'essai
c'est beaucoup et maintenant là
sur la place vide
il n'y a plus que des flaques de sang
[Musique]
mais les croates se
nous n'avons pas parlé des croix de feu
et bien ils nous ont manifestée aussi
ils ont commencé la veille parce que le
colonel de laroque préféré organiser une
manifestation indépendant et il faut
dire que on ne peut pas confondre les
croix de feu de la rock avec les autres
ligues laroque veut une réforme de la
république il ne veut pas jeter à bas la
république c'est ce qui explique
peut-être que il ne se joindra pas aux
autres place de la concorde ces sommes
vont le 6 février remonter le boulevard
saint germain sûreté à la force publique
magar violent
et ils enveloppent prend le palais
bourbon passeront par derrière pour
rejoindre les invalides
aurait-il pu infléchir le cours des
choses s'il avait été place de la
concorde
nul ne le saura jamais à minuit daladier
réunis aux affaires étrangères
ce ministre
c'est préfet les chefs de la police que
faut-il faire alors les jeunes ministres
radicaux jean mistler pierre kopp guy la
chambre sont à vis de résister et j'aime
trop le ministre de l'intérieur dit
qu'il faut faire front le lendemain et
la nuit s'est passée en
angoisse à l'incertitude
de la pensée que le lendemain tout le
monde risquait de se faire tuer bêtement
pourquoi
pas tellement inquiété j'ai demandé à
jean capte le 10 mai fait quelque chose
ne laisse pas ça m'a dit qu'est ce que
tu veux que je fasse musulmans là tes
amis politiques on va dire ma chérie tu
sais des hommes politiques sont des gens
foudre enfin je lui dirai sel quand même
il a fini par joindre andré tardieu qui
lui est la seule chose qu'il sait que
daladier dans sa démission et il faut
que ça soit le bras qui lui demandent ça
ne peut pas être nous le demandions
quand j'ai dit alors c'est fichu parce
que le bras n'a aucun courage civique
et le lendemain matin quand j'ai vu jean
avec son grand cordon dans légion
d'honneur
harry avec sa charte de députés sa
légion d'honneur la médaille militaire
et tous nos amis les chefs de ligue tous
avec leurs décorations tous les maires
avec leurs écharpes les députés avec
leur ainsi c'était vraiment bouleversant
de voir ce salon plein de monde on
attend d'elle et ne marcha lyautey est
arrivé en grand uniforme
mach que je revois encore quand le
tourner les yeux vers cette porte
vers 10 heures du matin hiverner
gaillette entrer dans ce salon est à dix
ils fichent le camp l'hallali et partait
et à ce moment là le colonel de laroque
a crié larmes au pied il a même été à la
fenêtre pour faire signer un sésame de
se disperser
daladier lis la presse qu'il a car il
est le fusil heures et puis quand il
apprend qu'on convoque une nouvelle
manifestation pour 18 heures ils
baissent les bras
[Musique]
voilà le président lebrun son ministère
il re téléphone au vieux gaston
doumergue
et cette fois doumergue accepte il sera
le 8 février à paris à la gare d'orsay
des milliers de français l'acclamant ils
ont trouvé une fois encore leur sauveur
[Applaudissements]
on a fait appel
à moi pour essayer
de constituer un gouvernement
d'entente et de concorde
je répondu à cet appel
je ne peux pas encore vous dire si je
réussirai ou non ça ne dépendra pas de
moi ça dépendra de ceux à qui je vais
demander série
13,6 soit la terre sous mafia bien qu'il
devait pas la peur j'ai pas mis les
moyens suffisants aux changer leur
mentalité mais j'ai conscience que
choisir que tout le monde comprendra
cette esthétique
et doumergue organisera un gouvernement
d'union nationale sans les socialistes
ni les communistes étendue largement à
droite grande première au ministère de
la guerre le barrage alpes est
alors maintenant c'est la gauche qui
n'est pas contente elle n'est pas
pourtant depuis des jours mais elle
trouve que ça a été trop et
la cgt
annonce la grève générale pour le 12
février le parti communiste lui convoque
une grande manifestation le 9 place de
la république la police y est elle tire
des morts autre manifestation en
banlieue la policiers elle tire des mâts
en tout ces journées insurrectionnelles
coûteront
27 main c'est trop
mais pour le 12 février le parti
socialiste convoque ses adhérents ses
sympathisants
au cours de vincennes
pour une grande manifestation le parti
communiste sans semble t'il avoir
consulté le parti socialiste organise au
même lieu le même jour à la même heure
une autre manifestation et à 15,1 sur le
cours de vincennes voilà deux immenses
cortège il semble qu'il soit 300 milles
qui s'ébranle de chaque côté de l'avenue
à la tête du cortège socialiste il y a
les robes l'eau vincent auriol à la tête
du cortège communiste il y a marcel
cachin jacques duclos vaillant couturier
elle s'avance parallèlement poussant des
cris qui ne sont pas les mêmes
chantant ensemble l'international
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
les jeunes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils vont arriver à la place de la nation
et là ils vont tourner autour de la
place et comme ils tournent chacun dans
un sens différent il est logique tu sors
ton
depuis des années ils ne s'aiment pas
beaucoup les partis socialiste et
communiste
peut-être sont-ils des partis frères
mais ce sont surtout les parkings mis
alors est ce qu'on va en venir aux mains
eh bien non un temps d'arrêt et ceux qui
sont à la tête des deux cortèges se
regardent
et tout à coup c'est l'os les uns vers
les autres se serrent les mains embrasse
bien et a donné essayé de faire dans le
passé naturellement j'avais les larmes
aux yeux je suis un peu un pleureur je
ne pense pas que la plupart des
militants ait eu les larmes aux yeux ils
ont un immense enthousiasme un immense
besoin de fraterniser avec les camarades
qui avait été leur adversaire politique
la veille hélas cela tient
essentiellement au fait que dans ses
profondeurs la classe ouvrière est
toujours a toujours été unitaire là ils
étaient réunies et il termine dans la
joie
est un crime ans qui monte unité
d'action unité d'action
discours chaleureux de kachin
de vaillant couturier de blum les
retrouvailles sont faites on y aura
encore bien des détours des difficultés
débrouille
mais finalement bout de la route que ce
côté
on trouve 1936
et oui vous le l'un des plus singulier
paradoxe de l'histoire c'est que ces
camelots du roi ces jeunesses patriotes
ces genres de la solidarité française
c'est francis tu es les croix de feu du
colonel de la roque
ont fait le 6 février
pour que naisse un jour le front
populaire
[Musique]